and yeah you heard that right what would
you say if I asked you to come be part
of that house it's deja vu for Peter
Webber
in a shocking first look at the new
season of The Bachelor it looks like
we'll be seeing a familiar face I I'm so
confusing at what are you doing here
making decisions for my heart because I
know there's still something there and I
would do anything for a relationship ET
spoke with the former Bachelorette
just this month about what advice she
did offer up to her former flame on
finding the one I think it's just taking
those moments to really get to know the
person without the cameras and to make
sure that you're really vulnerable and
honest with each other just because it
the the show is in your ended your life
is so start starting and to really get
to know like what you're in and be able
to make confident decisions for yourself
moving forward too just because the show
ends doesn't mean that's the ending you
really need to understand what your
relationship is and I hope that his is a
fairy tale and something that he's
always been looking for and it seems
like Peters fairy tale is just heating
up as the first look features multiple
shirtless moments Peter flies in and
he's
so freakin delicious like I just want to
wake him up and down
steamy make-out sessions I am falling in
love with Peter and I can't get enough
and of course lots and lots of tears I
can't understand how she could give up
there's so much right now and it's just
this is drawing my heart will see how
all the drama plays out when Peter
season premieres January 6th on ABC
[Music]